[music playing]
- Man, those percebes
were absolutely amazing.
But super simple.
Now according to Kiko,
they're not as simple to get.
He's arranged for me to
meet a very talented local
see barnacle harvester
who'll show me how to really
get these prized assets.
- Ricardo.
- Hey Gordon.
- Hi bud.
- It's amazing today.
- Good to see you, bud.
I'm so happy to be here.
- Ricardo Kazmi is a
percebes harvester.
That does not look easy.
- We'll see.
- He forages year-round for the
barnacles, and knows the waters
here like the back of his hand.
Look at those waves.
- Going to be rough.
The harder the waves are, and
the deeper the percebes are--
- Right.
- --the bigger they
are and the better.
- Per-seh-bi.
- We good.
Per-seh-bish.
- Per-seh-bish.
- Yeah, almost, almost.
- Let's go.
Wetsuit on?
- Yeah.
- Is size important for you?
Or thickness?
No--
- We're talking
about the percebes?
- We are talking about percebes.
- Of course it is.
- The thickness or the size?
- Both.
- 2 centimeters, and like
thickness of a finger.
- Gotcha.
- Those are the ones perfect.
- They will cost roughly
90, 100 euros kilograms.
- 100 euros a kilo?
- Yeah.
Because you're risking
your life doing this.
- Yeah [muted] I have to
check on my insurance.
Percebes are even harder to
gather than to pronounce.
Each year in Portugal, a handful
of people die collecting them.
Hopefully the ocean is
hungry for a new victim.
- We need to be
constantly watching.
Never turn your
back to the ocean.
Never.
- Never turn your back, no.
Got you, captain.
Man, you're like Spider Man.
Seriously, can you slow down?
Now all of a sudden you start
to see the size of those waves.
- You don't see them yet.
You will feel them.
Time to get wet.
- [muted] Really?
For a veteran like Ricardo,
this is a walk in the park.
But it makes me wish
I had a stunt double.
- Ready yourself.
- [muted]
- How was it?
We need to move from there.
- You can hide in
the [muted] hole.
- OK, Chief, now
it's the timing.
- Finding the right
size barnacles
takes incredible
timing, great strength,
and just a touch of crazy.
This is not like
foraging berries.
This is foraging on steroids.
[muted] now that is amazing.
Bloody hell.
Aren't they beautiful?
Really beautiful.
Wow.
- Now it's your turn.
But first we need to wait,
there is coming a massive set.
- Is there really?
- Look at the lines, let's--
- [muted] [muted] This is mad.
That is strong.
- Be careful.
- We need to move.
Stand.
- [muted]
- Gordon, hide, hide,
hide, hide, hide.
There is a big set coming.
[waves crashing]
- [muted] I can't get it.
- Let's search another hole.
- With the final cook
in a few days time,
failure is not an option.
So Ricardo suggest we try
our luck in a different spot.
- Try to catch those
ones, come on Gordon.
Got them?
Careful.
- You start to realize the
danger when you're chipping
away, the waves coming in.
You let go, do you
let go of the goods
do you save onto your life?
[waves crashing]
- Nice size.
- You did it.
- 100 euros a kilo.
One of the most
expensive shellfish
anywhere on the planet.
I see why now, because
they're the most dangerous.
- Let's go.
- Amazing.
This confirms how rugged,
but stunning this country is,
especially on the coastline.
Because look at it.
To the naked eye just looks
like waves pounding the rocks.
But there's so much
activity under there,
and it's incredible.
Good job, bud.
Honestly.
Amazing.
Adventurous, dangerous,
stupid and delicious.